flighty so high-level pizza Papa
well assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
better care to brothers and sisters and
dear friends hope you guys are doing
well welcome to reality 13 as you guys
know when this topic we're going to be
discussing the matter of do women play
the dumb role and when I mean dumb I
mean that do they act naive when it
comes to the matter of comity insects
also known as Zinner
now obviously before I start I want to
praise Allah support Allah the most
merciful the most trust or praise His
glory and gratitude belong to him for
and I want to produce these videos and
the works that we do now guys obviously
before I get into it the whole matter my
perspective and I'm going to read some
comments from Facebook and Instagram and
obviously snapchat as well when I ask
people to these questions and once
feedback basically from females about
this matter so I want to make it fair I
don't want it to be by Allah so it's
just my perspective on the off the
matter but before we do that we went to
the general public and interviewed
females on this matter and wanting to
get their feedback okay the question is
basically usually men tend to be after a
certain thing yeah do you think women
are oblivious to that they don't know
they're innocent of the matter I think
in our baby he's a good guy or do they
play the dumb game because they want to
do that but they just acting dumb
I feel no play like on thumb game okay
why do you think women play the dumb
game like what what do they get out of
it I don't know everyone has their own
reasons but maybe just so they don't
feel guilty about it I don't know they
know what again into yeah when they
first meet the boy yeah so they so they
know so usually play the dumb game yeah
but some girls don't think all boys are
like that and now fall for them
I don't think woman would act dumb
because they want the same thing yeah I
figured I'd dumb I think they would just
play along if they wanted to I think it
depends on apologies he wouldn't he'd
play along but I said is that
I'm sure every woman knows what they
want so like if that's what she wants
out the guy should just play along if
she wants something else yeah but do
some woman even though they want it but
they don't want the guy to know that
they want it do they play the dumb game
never you might get some women that do I
won't be like this everyone's different
in it
so in general women don't do together
women don't play dumb okay it's not only
know what again okay thank you very much
I actually think that some women are
hopeful that there's some decent men out
there that I'm not just after one thing
that's really good on Sep sure we
haven't quite got the answer so yeah
that's true what might actually agree
yeah I mean obviously there's the women
out there that want the same thing
so yeah they'll just go for whatever
they can get but they're actually chicks
out there who are looking for a decent
guy okay but do women ever use the duck
do you think right woman out there in
general terms they do play the dumb game
sometimes God you think it depends what
kind of woman she is because I wouldn't
want to play the dumb game I wouldn't
invest my time in a man that I know
only wants one thing that's dumb I think
women play the dumb game but at the end
of the day that's the woman that will
get her the most so really they're
probably not grown enough to know what
they're anyone they want it as well
they want as much as the men on it so
that's where they play dumb
yeah no no woman do you think oh no just
not with most women most women you -
most women would you say woman with no
mercy
they are oblivious so they know what no
some gals are some girls on okay I think
some girls will do it so they don't want
to make themselves look like a ho and
then some girls will so they will play
the dumb game cause they don't want to
be labeled as that's right yeah yeah
that's how I think
I don't know why do you think okay well
you actually said why they do that would
you say majority of women do that or
some some yeah just a lot of us girls
aren't like that yeah some of us don't
know some of us just think I really want
to be with this person and they'd be
like I probably nice me I would be like
cemented but if I found I just went one
thing I took yeah Tobby pistol in
football yeah yeah yeah okay thank you
very much well I think that they know
what's going on because it's kind of
obvious what this guy's around the only
after one finger saw I've been when I'm
playing innocent they just at like the
don't know what's going on but when the
playing the damn game
they kind of know what's going on think
what they want to get themselves into it
and then after they like they kind of
complain when they get out if you know I
mean why do they do that like obviously
when I say no every woman what about
some woman who played the dumb game like
what why do you think they do that is it
cause like they don't want to feel
guilty at the end of it I have no clue
to be honest I mean some some of them
obviously they want an innocent yeah um
it's not all women by the way only like
some type of women obviously but um
someone who lives is probably one of the
innocents worse okay just a quick
another question is obviously a lot of
men in that situation would go with the
flow yeah what advice would you give to
brothers out there in that situation
let's say they're they're the girls on a
she's blah blah blah
what would you say they should do
instead of saying you know what okay
she's on it let me be on it like well I
was it would evolve so too a Bravo if
you got a little sister just be aware
that whatever you do is kind of god
forbid this can act on your little
sister I mean Largo a little sister this
I know it's like some guys you saw that
for yourself and obviously we've got the
feedback from the females and some males
as well regarding this matter
now obviously you heard that now Robin
says the reason why I wanted to do this
video is very important because I didn't
they when I first started doing my
reality shows it was basically based
upon the things that I've seen when they
before I came to Islam things I've been
through etc and obviously I saw to my
perspective a lot of females suffering
more than males and become a victim to
males
men
promising give them false promises about
marriage blackmailing them getting them
to do certain acts and the list goes on
so due to this I concentrated the
reality shows based on advising sisters
more against meals and exposing how
males tactics are how they work and you
saw this in a reality shows reality part
one does he really love you reality part
two how many really thin reality free
shaytan's would did how a sister is
working some guy you know tries on
without work etc the reality for which
was I want a pious wife was against the
hypocrisy of men and the list goes on
about party now I always pick on guys
and I'm like men are players not all of
them obviously but my main consideration
of the area is to show this is the true
face of certain men and to say look
sisters be careful this these kind of
men out there do get I'm trying to say
and due to that I get a lot of criticism
from the Braavosi look at you why'd you
always fingers always meant always meant
always men and I'm not looking you're
right but you need to understand that
from what I see is always most of the
time it's meant that does this but now
with this show I wanted you guys to
understand that look it's not always men
because they're a woman out there who do
want to commit sin are like I said sex
they want to have sex and they act in a
naive way to get in there and I wanted
to find out does this really happen
today I'm trying to say and obviously
most of the people that we've talked
from Instagram snapchat that interviews
that we had in public you saw for
yourself say that woman play this role
they do this why to feel less guilty
they want to commit the act as well and
when when things got don't go to plan
they blame the guy etc etc so I want to
address the sisters at this point
because the video is aimed at them and
it's an advice now the matter of Xena is
a big sin it's a major sin Julie I'm
trying to say that's why I was front
Allah says in the Quran
don't even go near it you know Xena
don't even go near it and that is one of
the only sins well respond Tyler says do
not even go near it
so if you know Xena is here instead of
saying hey let me just walk around it no
Alice wanted I says go around the block
don't just even if you know okay no no
no go around the block now a lot of
people think when I almost want to says
don't go near zina it means don't go
near sexual intercourse know anything
that leads to that
stay away from it stay well away from it
and Alice one that says in the Quran in
surah Furqan verse 68 to 70 which you
can check for yourself I'm gonna power
phrase Allah says for those who commit
[ __ ] and murder and zina these are the
major sins and whoever does this I will
double the punishment for them on the
Day of Resurrection under their
judgement however for those who repent
sincerely not only will I forgive them
but turn their bad deeds into good deeds
so Alice want Allah's telling you the
major sins and if you commit them the
punishment will be doubled for you
however if you repent sincerely now how
do you repent sincerely brothers and
sisters number one we need to stop the
sin when technologies enough are
committed that you made a mistake okay
Allah fans Allah says all my servants
are trying to rest against their selves
never despair the mercy of your law
never despair the mercy of your Lord so
number one don't display those mercy for
you to think that Allah won't forgive
you is a sin within itself so number one
you've acknowledged you've been wronged
stop the sin repent sincerely repent and
make sure you do not go back to the sin
yeah and then shall obviously try to do
more good deeds so Alice want I wanna
only forgive you for that specific sin
inshallah we'll also turn it into good
deeds now brothers and sisters I
actually believe one of the main reasons
why sisters and brothers fall into this
sin is because the lack of tawheed a
lack of understanding who your Lord is
and the way to worship Him and your
Salah a Salah is very important rather
than sisters if you do not have that
connection with your Lord if you don't
even know who your Lord is and his
oneness and how to worship and not
through the grave or not rushing from
statues or going to these people who
tell you about your future coz you're
curious if you do not have your toe heat
on point if you don't understand your
Lord his word his lordship to worship
Him alone and singing singling him out
in everything that he does and having
your soul out on point what will happen
is you're going to go astray because you
have no connection with your Lord you
don't know you'll notice if you don't
know who your Lord is and you don't
acknowledge what he wants from you for
your own benefit then how could you obey
Him how could you obey Him when you
don't even know him you need to get to
know him and for you to have that
connection is your 5 day
so ah this is so important mothers and
sisters you need to have that because
the Salah keeps you away from these
things if you really treat have the
connection voila
inshallah over the finish of that you'll
be protected against zina and other sins
is or this is really important now I got
a message a couple of months ago for my
sister who said that she was invited to
a hotel room and in this hotel room
obviously she went there and she ended
up coming and zina and she will she
seemed surprised that I didn't know that
was going to happen
now obviously may Allah forgive the
sister etc but I'm just being realistic
and I'm not meaning a way of mocking her
but if a man is inviting you to a hotel
now my dear sis I'm stalking in general
right do you exit are you thinking that
you're going there because the brother
wants to play Monopoly with you like a
game of Monopoly or a game of chess you
need to understand that look there's two
things either you are really naive not
really really naive okay or you are
acting naive you know very well what's
going to happen there you know very well
why he's inviting you there you know
very well why he even asked for your
number in the first place and not didn't
and didn't do it in a halal way you know
so for you to be surprised and you're
going there and that happen and I'm
regretting it like I said you either
really naive or you're acting like and
this is what this video is about now
sisters you need to understand something
if a man approaches you on the street
and talking to you in a flirt way asking
for your number you need to acknowledge
that look there's this guy really want
to marry me or why is he approaching me
what is the reason behind him
approaching me
you know if he's talking to me and it's
telling me oh when you say okay I want
to get my brother involved he goes ah no
no no you need to think to yourself why
does he not want your family involved
why is he not speaking to you Wally why
is he not speaking to your brother why
does he want not
he doesn't want things to be in a halal
way you need to question yourself that
instead of making excuses for anything
in our you know like you meet somebody
he gives you promises or let me work I'm
still not ready for marriage you need to
think not make excuses for him you know
maybe you know he hasn't got work know
you need to say hold on a second you
know why why are you approaching me if
you are not ready for marriage if you're
not financially ready why
are you approaching me you need to think
like that otherwise you can't fool
yourself I think I let me make excuses
when maybe it's not really know if he's
not really why is he approaching in the
first place so you need to understand
sister specifically because otherwise
playing like I said before a lot of some
woman out there like we interviewed as
well they play the naive role and you
need to understand sister that you're
playing the naval or the other dumb role
should I say which is a matter that is
really major you talking about Xena here
you are acting naive on purpose knowing
that it is what you're doing about
getting to know him meeting up in
private nobody knows this is going to
lead eventually to some sort of a Xena
you know that so what you're doing is
you think you are fooling yourself or
you're fooling the other person or which
is even worse are you fooling Allah
think about that for a second are you
fooling Allah by thinking okay I'm gonna
act naive because I want to commit zina
with this guy so everything that you're
thinking in the head or anything the
Angels are writing it down don't you
think the Lord who has created you which
this is why I said the lack of tawheed
in yourself because if he had told you
will not allow the all-hearing the
all-knowing he knows what's within
yourself better than you so the fact
that you're thinking that you're fooling
yourself or you're fooling like the guy
opposite you are you fooling Allah think
about that for a second by sisters
please
are you fooling Allah and Brahmas you
could get into these acts as well who
are you fooling the one that created you
are you fooling him so sisters and
brothers and specifically a casette
sisters please acknowledge this but one
other point that I really want to
address before I come to the comments of
Instagram on Facebook this is really
important and I'm going to tell you guys
something real like I've heard it from
brothers myself I've heard it from
bravo's myself sisters I really want you
guys to listen there is a there was a
brother that I knew myself
right and he would tell me that he would
genuinely want to meet sisters for
marriage right maybe he was not going
about the right way but this was due to
him being new to Islam so he did not
know much so he didn't know about this
wali and etc so he was seeing a Muslim
sisters who wore hijab and didn't wear
hijab as well for marriage and he said
that he was gobsmacked he was gone
but he came to Islam and he's meeting
his sister's for marriage some hijab in
some non hijab' and that these sisters
were actually flirt with him and will
give him the hymn that they want to
commit sinner with him like they were
give him and this bubble will tell me
you know and he would say look one of
the things that he would do is this and
it is very important I want Brahma said
listen to this as well is that just
because a woman does not respect herself
when you are going to see this girl for
marriage and she starts acting all Buki
you know she start acting like you know
she wants to flirt with you and you can
hint that look if you go forward like if
you go with the flow you can end up
coming in Zinner
now this problem will say to me every
time this would occur that he would
really like Leslie there in a public
place coffee shop wherever or she's
given this hint or acting in a flirty
way he would really remind us he looks
at Stella please don't get me wrong but
I came in for marriage but you're really
acting in inappropriate ways and I see
you like my own sister and I feel really
sad now the reason why I'm telling you
this sisters and brothers is just
because a woman doesn't respect herself
and is acting in that manner does not
mean that you also disrespect because a
lot of guys say hey man she doesn't
respect us if I don't come just going to
use a lever this is not way this is not
what a Muslim man does this is not a
characteristic or a Muslim man you don't
say okay just because that person that
sister doesn't respect herself and she
wants to come as married you say I let
me go with the flow no this is not what
your deal is you should know better you
should say you know what sister I'm
sorry I came here for marriage but
you're acting in this way and you like
my sister I just want to give you a
couple of words the advice one lie by
Allah this this brother would say that
these sisters that he will talk to an
advice knowing how they would
inappropriately act with him would
message him couple of months down the
line and say brother that day I was
going through tests or this that family
problems and I lost then I just didn't
care about anything but the fact that
you didn't use me when I was vulnerable
you did not use me I said you know what
sister you like my own sister what like
why would you do this and advise me has
changed me today has made me a better
person the fact that you did not drop to
my level like that state when I was and
you advise me has changed me and I want
to say thank you and I want to say you
know like like the sisters would and
this is a true story you know
and this is what's so important just
because a woman is playing a naive game
or acting silly you know playing the
dumb role when I mean dumb word I'm not
calling sisters bump I'm seeing they act
dumb
what whereas they're actually clever
they know what they're doing if that
makes sense so just because a woman
doesn't respect herself as a Muslim man
or any kind of Man III advise anyone do
not drop to a level be the better person
and say sister I sent this in you and
you're trying to take down that route
but I don't want to go down that route
you're like my sister and advise that
person and I think this is the best way
how we as Muslim man should be even if
we see somebody not respecting their
self this is really important because
that could be your own sister and we
should really acknowledge that obviously
I don't want to go on further guys I
want to read the comments and hope you
guys have benefited inshallah
well let's just go through a few
comments by the MTA I said yes brother
Ali you are right some women do play the
main role in order to come as in our so
that they feel less guilty about it and
also deflect the blame onto the man
sister Samira says no woman are not dumb
when it comes to Xena they are just as
aware and down for it as men but some
woman or girls do get easily influenced
like they feel the need to commit add as
they want to impress the man I think you
should impress your Lord not a man you
know you know impress your Lord with
good deeds don't impress a man with bad
deeds
hurry
so Angela
okay citizen upset well it takes two to
tango so whether they're playing the
dumb role or not they most definitely
know what they're up to
there's no denying that since the
zum-zum a lot of girls know better but
they either have low self-esteem or they
asking for attention and so they ignore
the problem I think this is where the
being comes in making sure the
environment you do you're going to is
halal or you surround yourself with
other Muslim women who the religion for
the region first okay Arif says by the
air if some woman played the victim
under these circumstances but usually
they are the culprits instigating it men
don't approach the woman until the woman
give off some sort of a single please
don't hate me
hope nobody hates you you know we should
speak the truth even if it's against
ourselves cyano says to be honest a lot
of women and men don't even care it's
nothing about dumbing down they
literally just don't care okay okay it's
somebody said it's a 50/50 damn or not
both instigated both carry the opt-out
both are responsible that's the plain
truth okay so next verse says it depends
on each individual there are women who
are genuinely naive and not taking
advantage off I agreed also there are
women who are not so nice but maybe to
feel less beauty can use this an excuse
is it as an excuse to make themselves
feel less bad after then there are the
people who are just don't care either
way citizen Bravo should be so should be
selfish and think of themselves first
there is no one in the world who's worth
committing listen for respect yourself
very well said sister Patricia said some
woman I messed up sorry to say this low
self-esteem no confidence and they think
that the man will make them feel better
biggest in delusion first you need to
fix yourself before allowing another
person into your life I think we'll
leave out that brothers and sisters I
think you guys get the point like I said
before most of our videos are about
males but females are not perfect
yourself and like I said before bond and
sisters and the stand tall he'll
understand the connection with your Lord
have that connection with your Lord
move your Salah and inshallah with the
premiership I'll respond Tala you can
protect yourself from these filthy acts
you know these acts are nothing but
filth and the punishment is severe in
Islam you know and it's not worth it
bothers and sisters not only are you
degrading yourself but you're committing
a major sin for a purse
sin who on the day judgment is going to
ask a lot to throw you into the Hellfire
instead of him you know or vice versa
her so inshallah keep that in mind me
Alice once Allah grant every single one
of you guys Jannah make du'a for me
inshallah and may appear purify our
intentions and that's about PC subscribe
subscribe and do check out I've done a
video with mufti meant about these
matters forced marriages parents for
refusing a proposal how to protect
yourself from zina halal dating check
that out at the end of the video
assalamualaikum warahmatullah better
here
shoo-shoo shoo-shoo I know
shoo-shoo shoo-shoo